bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'actu sur tv fil 78
le journal de la rédaction de tv fils
voici quelques-uns des sujets que nous
aborderons ce soir en direct à 18 heures
la fête de l'aïd al kébir a débuté
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines a attrapé
un abattoir mobile a été mis en place
mille deux cents moutons sont proposés
aux fidèles elle si le rite musulman et
respecter les règles sanitaires
également nous verrons comment
travaillent les services de la
préfecture municipal avec le modem qui
s'organise dans les yvelines les chefs
de file ont été désignés quels sont ceux
qui devront mener campagne et ceux qui
devront composer des listes d'alliance
nous faisons le point et puis la
librairie inquiète de son avenir avec
les livres numériques
les ventes sur internet qui se développe
le plus ancien établissement de saint
quentin en yvelines à montigny le pavé
du canal pourrait d'ailleurs fermé si
aucun repreneur ne se manifeste son
fondateur nous donnera plus de
précisions il sera l'invité du 7-8
l'aktu l image du jour à présent c'est
donc la fête de l'aïd al-adha ou aïd el
kebir qui a débuté ce matin par la
traditionnelle prière regroupant les
fidèles comme ici à trappes à 8h30 une
prière différente des autres exercer
dans l'année puisqu'il faut pratiquer
des ablutions se vêtir de ses meilleurs
habits ne rien manger avant la prière
cette fête se veut un moment de
réconciliation de pardon de fraternité
elle est célébrée chaque année le
dixième jour du dernier mois du
calendrier islamique
en commémoration du sacrifice d'abraham
et je vous propose d'écouter quelques
uns des fidèles que nous avons rencontré
à l'issue de cette prière ce matin si la
fed et les rides et nous on est tous et
c'est un lieu sacré la mosquée c'est
pour qu'on vienne trier moi c'est
primordial est important surtout pour la
religion et c'est culturel aussi on va
continuer la journée un art où travaille
ou retour bas ont fini la fête à la
maison avec toute la famille va manger
on va tuer le mouton on va parler un
petit peu de religion voilà c'est la fin
du ramadan voilà c'est comme on dit chez
nous les rides et cube et à la
conclusion une moutons c'est un
sacrifice pour dieu mais voilà quoi un
seul abattoir est donc installée dans
les yvelines attrape ce matin le préfet
s'y est rendu pour un échange avec les
associations musulmanes il insiste sur
la difficulté à mettre en place ce type
de structure c'est une opération
complexe avec des équipements complexes
la ville d'elancourt posséder un
abattement doute puisque c'est elle qui
y organisait les années précédentes
cet abattoir elle a mis à disposition de
la casse qui cette année
généreusement et bénévolement donc je
pense que on va pas non plus multiplier
ce type de ce type d'abattoirs c'est
compliqué à faire c'est une grosse
organisation à la fois pour la commune
agglomérations et puis il faut des
opérateurs qu'ils soient compétents pour
le faire et là aussi ne sont pas légions
donc là on a une filière entre
guillemets je pense que il faut qu'on
les value définitivement et quand on
vérifie qu elle est capable de maintenir
et de se maintenir pour les prochains
lors de cette fête le rituel du
sacrifice doit être respecté les règles
sanitaires également une façon pour les
pouvoirs publics est d'encadrer cette
pratique trois vétérinaires quatre
techniciens sont dépêchés sur place à
trappes pour vérifier la conformité à
des carcasses catherine du nato et le
diwan derrière ses vitres les fidèles
peuvent assister au sacrifice des
moutons c'est l'aïd l'une des fêtes
musulmanes certains prennent même des
photos à rituels religieux qui n'échappe
pas aux règles sanitaires pour installer
un abattoir mobile comme ici à trappes
il faut d'abord déposer un dossier
d'agrément les sacrificateurs doivent
depuis cette année posséder un
certificat de compétences en termes de
bien-être animal et enfin l'installation
doit respecter l'environnement
pas question de rejeter de déchets
animaux en pleine nature et ce n'est pas
tout évitez de souiller les carcasses
dans le en termes de en termes de
d'hygiène alimentaire il va y avoir
toute la partie également en amont où il
faut que les animaux soit en bonne santé
donc ça on vient de vérifier auparavant
après pour tout ce qui est conditions de
salubrité des allume des aliments toutes
les carcasses sont inspectés par des
agents des services vétérinaires sur les
deux jours que va durer l'abattage les
services de la préfecture vont dépêcher
sur place trois vétérinaires et quatre
techniciens chargés d'inspecter donc les
carcasses et de rechercher les parasites
comme le ténia qui pourrait se mettre
dans le coeur ou le foie une fois
l'inspection terminée les fidèles
repartent avec leurs carcasses ex temps
piliers politiques à présent et le modem
dans les yvelines en ordre de marche
pour les municipales 38 candidats
viennent d'être désignés ils seront soit
tête de liste soit présent sur des
listes d'union le détail sur notre
secteur avec catherine gélato et
jonathan vilma le modem en ordre de
marche dans le département 38 candidats
sont pour l'instant connus soit il sort
en tête de liste soit les électeurs
pourront les retrouver sur des listes
villon
on est positionné à peu près partout
dans les villes de plus de 10 15 milles
habitants
on aura des candidats partout notre
mission au fait c'est déjà de soutenir
des projets locaux d'avoir des élus en
2014 c'est important on a les intercoms
qui se met en place il faut qu'on soit
représentée dans les conseils
communautaires les élections
sénatoriales qui approchent mais dans un
futur un peu plus lointain et il faut
qu'on soit très présent en termes de
représentation dans les yvelines
sur notre secteur certains emmèneront
une liste modem c'est le cas de jean luc
carrier à guyot pro il avait déjà
présenté viste dernières élections
municipales à un projet assez structuré
sur lequel on veut se battre pour
changer mon guyancourt pour être en
mouvement à guyancourt
parce qu'il nous semble que on est dans
les mêmes schémas depuis trop longtemps
il ya de plus en plus de gens qu'ils
s'aperçoivent que lui en cours est une
ville très séparés sur lequel il faut
mettre du liant de la démocratie locale
jean-luc arias devra batailler contre un
ancien modem julien oshry dans
l'opposition municipale il a décidé de
se rapprocher du maire sortant le
socialiste françois de ligne c'est un
choix personnel qui l'a fait que nous
regrettons mais il a fait ce choix de
quitter le modem et de quitter
donc notre travail c'est un choix
personnel dans les autres villes de
notre secteur les candidats modem feront
liste commune avec des formations à ces
diverses
ps europe ecologie les verts ou encore
ump c'est le cas de benoît corbin à
trappes
on le retrouvera sur la liste d'autres
menaces au site unique est absolument
passionnante par sa diversité aussi bien
éthique culturel que social et qui vont
me donner une vie dans laquelle on envie
de faire des choses depuis maintenant
plus d'un demi siècle c'est une ville
qui est gérée par la gauche que gérer de
façon totalement électoraliste pour
seule vocation de gagner des élections
année après année certains font le choix
de rallier les nerfs sortant mlpc le cas
à versailles on a
fait un énorme travail sur le terrain
deux versions versailles depuis hollande
énormément de réalisation dont on est
extrêmement fier je pense que le modem a
eu vraiment sa part sur françois nous a
vraiment il est souvent donné sa
confiance il n'y a aucune raison qu'on
reparte pas avec lui même cas de figure
à voisins le bretonneux malgré la
candidature d'une élue udi alexandra
rosetti elisabeth de vie terne biette
suit logiquement le maire actuel c'est
normal qu'on puisse continuer à
travailler ensemble sur les projets dans
une commune qui ne sont jamais
complètement aboutie d'un mandat au bout
d'un mandat qui se prolonge sur d'autres
mandats et voilà paraître c'est normal
de continuer à elancourt laurent vérat
est en pleine discussion avec dominique
lochon ancienne élue sur la liste du
maire sortant gare à michel fourbissent
yeux même s'il va falloir discuter les
du coeur du programme dans l'est dans
les semaines et les mois à venir
à titre personnel j'aimerais bien qu'une
chose soit mise en avant c'est un
programme pour le coeur de ville sur
elle en cours parce que je considère que
c'est une ville qu'il manque 2 qui
manque de
dans le coeur fait défaut à maurepas
georges bdf au visage une liste avec le
groupe modem des élections de 2008 à sa
soeur écoles et ville du quesnoy
travaille elle aussi sur une liste
indépendante
on va travailler pour proposer à notre
projet citoyen de manière à ce que la
vie sur saint cyr soit plus respectueuse
et au il fasse bon vivre son impression
que la ville commence à devenir une
ville dortoir où il n'y a plus de
commerce il n'y a pas d'association il
ya une vie et là je voudrais faire
revivre ma ville voilà les modems seront
donc un peu partout avec des thématiques
communes la démocratie locale la
maîtrise des dépenses et le
développement durable le parti de
françois bayrou compte environ 600
adhérents dans le département
politique toujours à maurepas la
situation à droite s'éclaircit pour
certains s'obscurcit pour d'autres l'ump
départementale étaient réunis en comité
lundi soir pour donner ces dernières
investitures à maurepas
elle a été donnée à grégory gars restiez
responsable l'ump locale qui s'étaient
déclarés depuis le mois de mars et qui
siège au conseil municipal de maurepas
depuis la fin du mois de septembre il
écoute je suis très heureux que ma
famille à laquelle j'appartiens depuis
depuis sa création mais fait confiance
pour cette élection municipale et pour
la représenter en tant que tête de liste
c'est le choix de la cohérence c'est le
choix du mérite de la confiance
et puis c'est le choix du renouvellement
voilà je pense que ma famille politique
a aussi misé sur le renouvellement
vraiment des générations amara dont on
avait besoin pour préparer l'alternance
ma légitimité voilà il est reconnu
officiellement par mes pairs et j'en
suis très heureux et je remercie
également tous les soutiens aux héros
merci
surtout mon technophobes façon grégory
guerre et astier a également reçu
l'investiture du parti
chrétien-démocrate l'ump des yvelines
l'add on préféra pire le guérinel ancien
premier adjoint udi de georges mougeot
le maire sortant pierre leguérinel qui
avait pourtant le soutien de valérie
pécresse la patronne de l'ump
départementale il se déclare donc
surpris de cette décision il parle d'un
mauvais calcul et même d'un signe de
faiblesse de ce parti pour rappel pierre
leguérinel compte actuellement sur sa
liste en numéro 2 nicole malaquin ump
elle a été longtemps responsable de la
section locale de ce parti sur la ville
demeure pas l'énergie de demain tout
autre sujet et coûtera très cher
certains l'ont compris n'hésite pas à
rénover leur habitat pour éviter de
futures factures énergétiques très salée
c'est le cas d'antoine désir à magny les
hameaux découverte de sa maison passive
puisque c'est comme ça qu'il faut
l'appeler avec ce sujet d'olivier
maniscalco et elodie moines antoine
désir habite à magny les hameaux
en trois ans il a transformé son simple
pavillon de banlieue en maisons passives
aussi appelée maison sans chauffage
le principe d'une maison passive c'est
qu'on profite des apports du soleil et
des apports internes par exemple des
habitants pour chauffer la maison et
donc pour ça le principe c'est de ne pas
perdre de chaleur à travers les murs par
exemple et donc il faut beaucoup
l'isoler et chez antoine désir tout a
été rénové pour devenir passif en
isolation extérieure est assurée avec
des blocs de 50 cm de polystyrène
graphite est collée au mur au sous sol
c'est du polyuréthane qui recouvre le
plafond une partie des murs les fenêtres
sont en triple vitrage et permettent une
grande étanchéité à l'air pour le toit
c'est plus écologique dans le choix des
matériaux ouate de cellulose et fibre de
bois aujourd'hui fait humide entre
dehors il fait 22
dedans il n'y a pas de chauffage
chauffage qui de toute façon et d'une
puissance très faible 1 dans une maison
comme ça dans le détail on utiliser ces
serviettes des salles de bain pour
choper la mer antoine désir ne s'est pas
arrêté à l'isolation 40 tubes solaires
sont installés sur le toit pour chauffer
l'eau des panneaux photovoltaïques et
servent à l'auto consommation
d'électricité le clou de sa rénovation
c'est son système de ventilation double
flux qui récupère toute la chaleur
intérieure de la maison
cette chaleur est conservée mélangé à
l'air qui vient de l'extérieur est
renvoyé dans la maison qui est donc
chauffer gratuitement
ce qui est intéressant dans ce progrès
avec la maison à la base et une maison
très conventionnel donc ça peut
concerner un peu tout le monde qu'un
pavillon
c'est la cas de dix ans je n'avais
quasiment aucun projet de ce type là ni
écologique ni passif ni bbc et
aujourd'hui on a sur le territoire du
parc naturel régional qui représente 51
communes de nombreux projets qui sont
réalisés ou qui sont en train d'émerger
ce type de construction permet à long
terme des économies
antoine désir a vu sa facture
d'électricité de 2500 euros par an / 5
mais cela reste une histoire de passion
écologique pour sa maison le magnet quoi
à débourser pas moins de deux cent
cinquante mille euros crédit d'impôt
inclure le 7-8 l'actus poursuit dans un
instant je recevrai sur ce plateau et
ricard d'un libraire gérant fondateur de
cette librairie le pavé du canal à
montigny le bretonneux et il est déjà
avec nous nous parlons de l'avenir de
son établissement
mais pour l'instant dans le cadre de la
semaine du mal de dos les chiropracteurs
offre des consultations gratuites
jusqu'à vendredi pour vous permettre de
faire un bilan dorsale l'occasion de
découvrir cette technique médicale non
médicamenteuses avec anthony rech
non nous ne sommes pas dans le cabinet
d'un ostéopathe
mais chez un chiropracteur spécialiste
des relations entre la colonne
vertébrale et le système nerveux le
chiropracteur va uniquement opéré par
manipulation après avoir détecté
l'origine des douleurs
même si la quiero peut être miraculeuse
dans ces résultats c'est quand même rare
d'avoir des résultats définitifs en une
seule séance
c'est quand même un travail qui peut
s'étaler en général sur cinq six séances
pour déjà améliorer les symptômes qui
ont conduit la personne à consulter le
chiropracteur exerce aussi de la
prévention sur les mauvaises positions
et le stress pendant toute cette semaine
du mal de dos catherine parodie recevra
une quinzaine de personnes en
consultation gratuite pour faire un
bilan dorsale mais pas seulement on
s'intéresse à toutes les articulations
du corps les extrémités et khalid est
donc bon c'est vrai qu'encore une fois
on s'intéresse à la colonne vertébrale
parce que elle recouvre la moelle
épinière et que tous les nerfs qui vont
vers les différents organes les muscles
les articulations partent de là chez ce
praticien la première visite coûte 65
euros puis 50 euros pour les suivantes
la consultation n'est pas prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale mais peut
être remboursé par la mutuelle invité
donc de cette édition du 7 8 l'actuaire
écart d'un bonsoir libraire gérant
propriétaire fondateur du pavé du canal
à montigny le bretonneux établissement
qui fait partie un peu du patrimoine
local de 50 1,24 année d'ouverture
et pourtant la question de votre avenir
se pose demain mercredi vous inviter les
fidèles clients et les autres aussi
autour d'une réunion d'une discussion un
apéritif du débat à 19 heures pour
parler de la situation de l'évolution
dans les prochaines semaines les
prochains mois également votre
établissement est il aujourd'hui menacée
de fermeture
et si oui à quelle échéance menacée je
dis non au jeudi à puisque des faits
l'activité commerciale continue et au
contraire se développe plus tôt avec
hélas la fermeture de virgin mais qu ils
vous renvoient des clients non il ya une
double question qui se pose sur le pavé
du canal qui est d'abord celui de ma
succession j'ai 64 ans bientôt et bien
sûr je cherche sortir par le haut niveau
du de la librairie et des activités
professionnelles premièrement et puis si
la main de repreneurs qui se soient
manifestés pour nous on a eu différentes
touches différentes personnes mais ils
ont fui un peu devant la question en
effet des loyers et des charges puisque
on est en période de renouvellement du
bail et que la de ce point de vue là on
est en pleine discussion avec le
propriétaire
on peut savoir combien coûte justement
une telle location vous est si différent
c'est bon tu ne parles du centre
commercial ne se passe sans quand un
bébé coûter entre les charges entre le
loyer et les charges que leucate yvon
paye deux cent sept mille euros par an
voilà donc ils font un chiffre
d'affaires conséquent pour continuer à
rester implanté sur un tel site un oui
tout à fait c'est un des problèmes de la
librairie c'est qu'un effet les ratios
habituels de la profession ne sont pas
respectées c'est pas un problème qui non
seulement la libre et le pavé dit
quesnel souffrent puisque vous avez pu
voir qu'à travers la france il y a le
problème en effet des loyers en centre
ville pour les activités de faible
rentabilité comme la librairie se pose
et on a eu des fermetures de librairie
de ce fait donc c'est vrai que je me
pose la question et j'aimerais quand
même pour le premier trimestre de
l'année prochaine
trouver des solutions car peut-être un
repreneur se manifestera demain lors de
ceux de ce rendez vous ce qui freine
peut-être les repreneurs potentiels se
sont toutes les inquiétudes autour de ce
secteur de la librairie on peut les
évoquer la vente en ligne par exemple à
la concurrence aussi des grandes
surfaces qui ce qui de plus en plus
propose des livres toute cette
concurrence aujourd'hui vous
le sentais véritablement sur le chiffre
d'affaires les ventes en ligne par
exemple les ventes sur internet pas les
livres dématérialisés n'est vraiment la
vente
oui internet je pense que la librairie
souffre ou est impacté par deux choses
essentielles qui est un effet la vente
en ligne
et là il y avait une concurrence
déloyale qui était faite de par le
dumping qui était faite par notamment
des grands acteurs comme amazon à
travers la gratuité des frais de port
qui vient de trouver un issue puisque en
effet le parlement a voté à l'unanimité
et sur proposition d'une loi qui
provenaient de l'opposition vous quand
même le signaler donc voté une
modification de la loi sur le prix
unique pour le livre qui rendra beaucoup
plus difficile de dumping que fait des
grands acteurs dont amazon sur les frais
de port le deuxième problème c'est bien
sûr en effet le numérique il la place du
numérique la vente dans les grandes
surfaces spécialisées hélas vous voyez
que ça a été mal menée puisque vers jean
affirmé que la grande chaîne qui étaient
issus de bertelsmann chapitre ferme
enfin a annoncé qu'il se donnait un an
pour trouver une solution pour leurs 57
librairie donc non les grandes surfaces
spécialisées sont plutôt mal menée
actuellement est bien pire que la
librairie indépendante qui résiste
beaucoup mieux alors ou achetez-vous vos
livres justement nous sommes allés poser
la question dans les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines non loin de votre
établissement et vous allez pouvoir
réagir juste après suffit dès là une
librairie
petite librairie de quartier j'aime bien
les livres donc du coup je préfère les
feuilletés donc non rarement grandement
par internet librairie internet moi
j'aime bien le conseil du libraire donc
j'aime bien racheté en librairie mais je
passe toujours par la librairie
même si j'ai cherché sur internet avant
en plus par internet plus par internet
ne bouge pas de la maison puis au moins
on n'a plus de choix je commence par
rapport à ce qu'on veut justement ça
tombe bien vous dites ça parce qu'ils
vont la ferme et apparemment il parle de
la ferme bien coincé un coin bd qui est
plutôt sympa pour mon enfant qu'à trois
ans ça fait trois ans que j'ai acheté
des tout ce qui est bon dessiné pour moi
et pour le petit ici à la librairie du
pavé alors voilà justement on a
rencontré un de vos lecteurs nos
adhérents fidèles un des lecteurs qui
vient s'approvisionner dans la librairie
du pavé du canal
comment on fait la différence
aujourd'hui pour justement faire venir
les clients dans son établissement par
rapport à cette concurrence d'internet
dont on attendait parlais tout à l'heure
une des personnes interviewées du choix
du libraire oui je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs choses d'abord il faut leur
simplifier la vie
donc en effet les librairies pavé
puisque le pavé dans la mare a également
participé à ce site internet nous avons
développé ensemble un site internet qui
a une base de données de 1 million 400
mille titres qui est actualisé tous les
jours par les éditeurs avec les
nouveautés des éditeurs les prix la
disponibilité
il est client depuis chez eux peuvent
voir notre stock c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent depuis chez eux
commandez réserver ou commander les
ouvrages et devenir qu'une fois à la
librairie dans les librairies que ce
soit la marque ce soit ou pavés du canal
chercher leur livre donc ça c'est une
réponse qu'on fait secundo et ben c'est
aussi sur le choix des livres 1 et là
c'est important puisqu'il paraît à peu
près 60 7000 livres par an dans en
france que le catalogue de l'édition
française c'est à peu près 700 mille
titres disponibles que hope avait dû
canal nous devons avoir à peu près 42 à
44 mille titres différents à l'intérieur
de la librairie donc c'est en effet
notre choix donc on veut être le reflet
des éditeurs et de l'édition française
vis-à-vis d'une population mais
également les aspirations de la
population les attentes de la population
et puis nos coups de coeur
et nous nous mise en avant vous parlez
de yaba et animations et vous parlez de
ce lien justement avec le pavé dans la
marre là c'est du côté des longs cours
vous êtes un bon tennis et je parle de
cet établissement parce que c'est
peut-être là aussi un message d'espoir
pour les repreneurs potentiels ce site
que vous avez également fondé dont vous
étiez propriétaire vous avez réussi à
trouver un repreneur serait l'encours
récemment non ce ne sont pas des
repreneurs se sont mais les employés
qu'ils en tout cas libre est libre et à
des libraires professionnels qui ont
repris le pavé dans la mare il a fallu
faire quelques sacrifices mais j'étais
bien content d'assurer une continuité
sur le centre 17 mar de la librairie le
pavé dans la mare donc c'était très très
bien et ce sont des vrais libraires
professionnels qui développe un projet
personnel et puis avec l'essor du centre
17 mar la réouverture des trois salles
de cinéma l'etrat le prisme la
médiathèque qui fonctionne très bien
ils les ont des activités ils s'en
sortent très bien donc ce site devrait
prospérer
quel avenir pour cette profession des
libraires cette profession de libraire
vous la voyez comment dans quelques
années je crois que ligne aura toujours
le livre papier 1 et que le numérique ne
viendra pas totalement balayé le livre
papier
les ebooks 0 26 % du marché total du
livre
oui c'est ça entre les ebooks entre les
téléchargements les smartphones et
autres oui on dit grosso modo que c'est
un pur savez c'est pas un marché
qu'encore beaucoup émerger et qui est
assez compliquée au niveau des drm au
niveau des puisque sa question nous dit
ce marché va exploser ce marché va se
développer et se développe il se
développer dans d'autres pays d'europe
oh non grande bretagne entre autres aux
etats-unis non parlons pas je crois
qu'ils y seraient amenés à se développer
mais le livre papier reste et restera
alors maintenant c'est vrai que pendant
pendant trente ans on agrandit les
librairies développer les linéaires les
surfaces
le nombre de titres disponibles il va
peut-être falloir rétrécir un tout petit
peu
nos librairies et trouver d'autres
activités et de tous à vous en
discuterait forcément demain lors de
cette réunion cet apéritif débat autour
de l'avenir du pavé du canal notamment à
montigny le bretonneux les enseignements
qui s'affiche à l'écran père cédric à 19
heures à 19 heures ne manquez pas ce
rendez vous on reste dans le monde des
livres le monde des bulles plus
précisément à présent avec le festival
de la bande dessinée de but qui fêté ses
20 ans lionel torrès j'en attends
willeman sont allés rencontrer les
auteurs présents mais aussi les
bédéphiles bédévores vous allez faire
connaissance avec philippe fleuret il
est présent à chacune des éditions
depuis 20 ans philippe est un abonné en
vingt ans il n'aura pas raté une seule
édition de ce festival de bande dessinée
de buc
et comme chaque année ce bédéphiles
venue de cannes ne repartira pas les
mains vides
c'est une série qui fonctionne très bien
et ça plaît bien au public non moins pas
de temps à perdre philippe s'empresse
d'aller à la rencontre de l'auteur pour
la dédicace c'est un avantage de ces
festivals lorsque les auteurs sont sur
place
on a la chance d'avoir un
dessin c'est fort sympathique de
festival en festival philippe nous de
véritables amitiés avec ses auteurs
favoris comme régric pour se connaître
donc depuis 23 ans
donc et puis voilà donc s'affirmer voir
l'évolution de l'auteur emma merci mon
ami merci au revoir
il
donc il a fait celle-ci voilà donc celle
là il a fait un personnage il a pas fait
le héraut il a fait un personnage de
l'histoire c'est le professeur vers
d'ailleurs
aarhus et puis voilà et puis là il a
doublé en deux ans en rajoutant qui
petite dédicace personnalisée
alors j'ai à peu près l'ensemble de mes
bd j'en ai un peu près 1500 ans tous
confondus
tout confondu avec les époques et j'en
ai à peu près 900 dédicacer ce qu'il
affectionne tout particulièrement c'est
la bd franco belge des années 50 à 70
une passion qu'il vit depuis plus de 50
ans c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui c'était
pour la même époque les histoires
étaient plus saine et elle était très
bien très bien dessiné très bien très
bien conçu et tout le monde pouvait lire
ces bandes dessinées à partir de
l'enfance jusque jusqu'à la période
adultes c'est ce qui m'a toujours plu
j'ai été élevé avec le journal tintin le
journal spirou d'époque
alors vous imaginez aujourd'hui et j'ai
accumulé tout six histoires ça c'est
album que l'on à faire donc je suis
arrivé aujourd'hui m
une belle collection qui prend beaucoup
de place beaucoup d'argent
surtout de la place de la place il va
encore en falloir pour ces nouvelles bd
et on avait déjà les éditions originales
mais aujourd'hui il a acheté une
réédition avec les nouvelles couvertures
une bonne passion c'est simple il faut
savoir lire et comprendre le monde nous
voit la fin de ce journal a retrouvé en
replay sur notre site internet
rendez vous demain 18h toujours en
direct bonne soirée